Hey team, a very warm welcome to your 90-day goal setting template.
Now this works in partnership with the top five goals that you set every week.
Now again, why goal setting important?
It helps us as a company in each of our sections or departments all know what are our goals,
what are we all working on?
And it helps us in terms of better understanding each other and making sure that we're heading
in the direction of the vision that we're working towards.
So everything begins with the 90-day goals.
So this is done typically before the top five goals.
And why is that?
Because then once you've got this larger vision, you then pull what's needed for the
week ahead of you.
Now the 90-day goals also has a very short version of the yearly goal and the five-year
goal.
Now don't worry about getting this all done perfectly.
My recommendation is just get the first one done in a very short amount of time.
Just work through it and get familiar with the process.
Now this is a complete template that Community Angels team have completed.
I'm going to walk through this with you to have a look at some examples of how this actually
looks and let's take a look together.
So this is the first section and you'll complete this on your computer so we have a digital
version of this that we can store in the company files.
Now we've got the department so here it's the CAA team.
At the moment there's no real divisions inside Community Angels because we're very small.
But as it grows we'll have different divisions or departments inside that.
So when it comes to you, it's going to be your department here, Landcare department or
the Building Maintenance Team department or Management department, whatever it may be,
whatever your department is, whatever we call your department because that's still being
defined.
Okay, now the date range is 90 days from when this is completed.
Now when it comes to the grand vision dream, what is that?
Well, we're just going up now into the why.
Why are we doing this?
And this is to do with your department.
Your department has a why.
Now you could be thinking of yourself as, oh, I'm just taking care of trees, there is
no big vision or dream.
No, that's not the case.
What is the dream?
What is the bigger inspiration behind what you're doing?
Whether you're building bricks, whether you're planting trees, what is it?
And so here this is about you in the B. So you'll notice here it says B, do and have.
Now this part's been typed in here, but what your template should have is B, do and have.
Now B is more of an emanation from your being.
So for the Community Angels team, one of their visions is to be inspiring to others.
It's not just about helping the elderly or helping, you know, traffic children.
We want to inspire others to care, to have heart, to have love.
So here the team have put an inspiring reference.
So others can look at you and be inspired.
So that's who they want to be in themselves.
Now in your department it might be completely something different.
It will be something very different.
And that's for you to just jot down.
And this is more about a beingness, who you're being.
Then the next part is what are you doing?
So what are you doing from the being?
So in this case it's sustainable and impactful acts of charity.
So they want the acts to be sustainable and impactful, touching the lives of people while
empowering networks and leaders to do the same thing.
And that's the inspiring reference part.
So see how that connects.
Then when it comes to have is a treasure network of elderly, charity, financial partners, ecosystem
and value.
So that's what we want to actually achieve.
Now I haven't gone through this so I'm interpreting this from the team as I'm live here with you
on this video.
So if I was with the team I would ask them, tell me what you mean a bit more by treasure
network and what you mean by that just to understand it.
But of course when you're doing this for your own department you're going to know what that
is.
You're going to understand what it means.
Okay so now we look at mini wigs.
So they're called a wig stands for wildly important goal.
So that's something that matters to us here at EdenRite or working on.
So again, be who we being here in one year.
Again this is what the team have come up with.
Then what are they doing for this one year.
Now of course it's going to evolve constantly but we're just doing this to forecast and
get our vision in the right direction.
That's the purpose of this.
And now it becomes the first a bit more tangible.
We want to have three big sponsors and have received 5000 euro and have 12 angel volunteers
and establish a system that holds that together.
Again I'd like to know what that means to hold.
I would ask the team what they mean by that.
But again that's what you're looking at.
What's the tangibility.
Now in your department it might be we want to complete these particular things on EdenRite.
We want to have this all organized and etc.
Now of course I would be like to see these and look at your thoughts and have feedback
with you to make sure it connects to the bigger vision that I'm also there to stew it.
So we all we work together in this process.
But I want you guys to have a go and just do this for yourselves and it will really be
amazing to see what you come up with.
And you'll be driving this process every 90 days not me but I'll be working with you
in this process.
So let's take a look at the next one.
So then we've got the 5 year goals.
That's a bigger thing here.
Now that may or may not be relevant to your department or maybe you can see it.
Maybe you can't.
If you can't just just just put down what you can.
Now here the 5 year goals we want to have half a million donations.
We want to have a thriving national charity ecosystem with international impact.
So that's the goal here that the team have.
Okay so then when it comes down to departments and again remember this is within the side
your department.
And then you have your department and then you have sub departments within that.
So with community angels there is sections within that.
Obviously that's the administration side of it.
This is the goals they have here for the areas to work on and then the outreach and then
the financial side of it.
So there we go.
First two pitches to local leaders.
Okay cool.
So again I'm discovering this as I go through this with you now.
So then we just summarise here.
You see our simbilities just a few words just to get the thinking and the focus.
The big outcomes for the 90 days the quarter.
Well here the team have it as you know define a budget an operational budget for community
angels.
High quality work environment.
We want to get a thousand euros of a donation from someone and three active and official
volunteers.
Social media and organizations such as to create the social media get it going.
So that's their goals.
Then we look at values.
Now when I used to do this with professional teams and athletes and their coaches we used
to have anywhere up to 12 values.
Here we're keeping it super simple.
We're just asking to come up with three for the community angels team.
It's love.
The quality of being intrinsically guiding us.
So really to embody love to bring love wherever they go and to take action and visible movement
unfolding because you know one thing is to have love and then to take action is another
thing and then they've got power here which is voltage or potency of intrinsic expression.
Again I'd love to know what that means but they know what that means for them.
Okay so coming down the I think it's the final section here.
It's called smart goals.
It's an acronym for making sure that the goals are specific.
You can measure them.
If you can't measure it it doesn't really count.
And achievable so they're realistic that you can achieve them or that the realistic is
the next part and then there's a time frame that you're setting for those goals.
So that makes this this is a smart way of setting goals.
So here you've got the team again doing it in the different departments.
There's financial goals there defining budgets receiving donations.
There's a three month timeline for that and then so forth.
And I believe yeah that's it.
So that's the template.
So have fun completing this.
This is a high priority.
This needs to be done and completed this week.
No questions asked.
This is something that we've got to make time for.
Will make time for.
And then once again this is only done once every 90 days or three months and the top
fives are done every single week and that keeps us really tight in the line.
So I trust you guys have enjoyed this.
You will have the template in the group as well.
If you want any guidance with this please ask questions.
Ask Joao or myself and know that this is not about perfection.
It's about getting it done and we will refine this every 90 days.
And it's a beautiful thing.
It gives us a lot of clarity, a lot of inspiration and make sure that we're all on the right
direction.
All right.
Thanks guys and take care.